during in-game's five-year time Jump we
learned that Tony Stark retreated from
the public eye and had a daughter named
Morgan Stark with the love of his life
Pepper Potts realizing that he has a
responsibility both to the universe and
to his own beloved family Stark
heroically offers up his own life so
that the Mad Titan can be defeated once
and for all during a recent appearance
on MTV's happy sad confused podcast
co-directors Joe and Anthony Russo
revealed that Catherine Langford had
been cast as an older version of Morgan
she was supposed to appear to Stark in
the same Netherworld where Thanos finds
young Gamora in Avengers Infinity War
does this plot development sound
confusing to you if so the directors
wholeheartedly agree and that's why
Langford scene ultimately wound up on
The Cutting Room floor as co-director
Joe Russo explained the intention was
that his future daughter forgave him and
sort of gave him peace to go and the
idea felt resonant but it was just too
many ideas in an overly Complicated
movie